given a rectangle with length a squared
plus 6a minus 27 and with a squared
minus 9 right the ratio of the width of
the rectangle to its length as a
simplified rational expression and
rational expression is kind of a fancy
word essentially for a fraction or as a
ratio so they want to raise right they
want us to express the ratio of the
length the lengths we'll put the length
in the numerator the length to the width
the length to the width and in the
problem they tell us that the length the
length right here is a squared plus 6a
minus 27 a squared plus 6a minus 27 and
then the width the width they tell us
right here is a squared minus 9 so the
width is a squared minus 9 so we've
already expressed it as a rational
expression but this isn't necessarily a
simplified rational expression and
whenever you have any rational
expression let's say we have let me just
go back to what you learned long time
ago if I had something like 2 over 6
that's a rational expression or that's
also a fraction but this isn't in the
most simplified form what you could do
is you factor both of these you could
say well 2 is 1 well it's just well if
you a prime factorization it's just 2
but 6 is 2 times 3 so when you factor
them you see that you have the same
factor in the numerator in the
denominator you can cancel them out and
you can simplify it to 1/3 now we're
going to do the exact same thing with
these algebraic expressions we can
factor them and then see if they have
any of the same terms if they have the
same terms on the numerator and the
denominator then we can cancel them out
and then we'll just be left with what
we'll be left with whatever is left over
so let's see if we can factor this
numerator right here so this is going to
be equal to let me draw the line there
so a squared plus 6a minus 27 can we
think of two numbers that if we multiply
them we get negative 27 and so they're
gonna have to be of different signs
because they when you multiply we get a
negative number and when you add them
you get positive 6 let's see 9 + 9 -
three is six nine times negative three
is negative 27 so this top expression is
a plus nine times a minus three we
factored it there and then what is this
bottom expression factored into well
this is that standard form if you know
if you remember a squared minus B
squared where in this case B would be
three B squared would be 9 and we know
that this is equal to a plus B times a
minus B so in this situation we know
this is a special form that would be
factored into a plus three times a minus
three now we see there is a term that is
common to both the numerator and the
denominator a minus three you have an a
minus three in the numerator and you
have an a minus three in the denominator
so we can divide the numerator and the
denominator by a minus three or that
they would cancel out or a minus three
divided by a minus three assuming that a
is not equal to three because then it
would become undefined but if we assume
a does not equal to three something
divided by itself will just be one right
there and then we'll just be left with
we'll just be left with a plus nine a
plus nine over a plus three and that's
about as simplified as we can get for
this rational expression